In the next three lessons we will explore a data set that
resembles user activity on Facebook but before we get to that data
set I need to show you how to read in data that
doesn't come with R and how to subset that data. It turns out
that not all data sets can be easily loaded like the empty
cars data set. In the instructor notes you can find a link to
download a new data set. This data set is going to contain
information on the fifty states in the US. Most of the data comes
from about 1970. Before we can read in the data, we
need to set our current working directory. So, to figure out
what directory you're in now, you can type in getwd. We
can run this command and see the output to the console. It
looks like I'm already in the downloads file, and that also
appears here in the top of my console. So I don't
need to change my directory, but maybe you do. To change
your directory, you can type setwd. This will take a string which
will be the file path to what ever directory you want to
go to. My guess is that your data set is in your
downloads file. So I would probably run this command. Now it's important
to note that whether or not your on a Mac or Windows machine
you still need to separate your paths or your folders with a
forward slash. Also be sure that you use quotes around your path. Now
in order to load up the data, we can use the read.csv
command. This command takes a string, which is the name of the file.
And here we're going to pass it to a variable called
statesInfo. StatesInfo is going to save all of our data
into a data frame. When I run this code, I can see
that statesInfo appears in my environment. I can double click on
the data frame in the work space, and this will let
me see the table of values in RStudio. Now, let's say
I wanted to get information on states located in only the Northeast.
Those states would be states like Connecticut and they have a state
region of one. I'm going to go back to my R-script
and write a command that pulls in this data. This
subset command would look like this. Here I'm passing the
data frame statesInfo to subset and I'm asking for
it to retrieve any states that have a state.region equal
to one. When I run this code I can see
the output down below. We have Connecticut, Maine, and many
others. Now, there is another way to subset this data frame.
And I want to show you it, just so that way, you don't
get confused later if you see it. It uses bracket notation, where we
have the name of our data set, followed by two brackets. And we'll
have a comma in between. This first spot is for the rows of our
data set. That we want to keep. And the second spot is for
the column's that we want to keep. So if I want only the
states in the Northeast, I would write this code. The name of the
data set is statesInfo and then I want the rows that have a
state region equal to one. Now I can't just use state region
here, I need to access the actual variable, so I have to
put statesInfo and the dollar sign. This gives me the actual
variable value and I can see if it's equal to one. If
it is equal to one, I want to return every single column in
the data frame. So for example, with Connecticut if it's state region
is equal to one. I want to return every single column in this
row. To return all of the columns, I'll just leave this blank.
So this code searches for rows that have a state region
equal to one. And then it takes all the columns in that
row. And all of this will be sent to the console as
a new data frame. Now it might not be so helpful to
have this output just in the console. So we can save these
subsets into new variables. I'm also going to include some functions to print
out the first two rows of each data frame, and also their
dimensions. Hopefully, I've convinced you that they're the same data set. Now,
I really want you to pay careful attention to the syntax
in both of these examples. Throughout this course, we tend to
make use of the subset command, but there might be instances
where we use this. Just know that both methods produce the
same result. Now, I recommend that you try subsetting this data
frame for other regions of the country on your own. You
could also try finding out which states have an illiteracy rate
of 0.5%, or which states have high school graduation rates above 50%.
Feel free to play around.